my dad found gay porn on my computer
before I came out seems like something
that I've always known I can't pinpoint
like a day I knew what gay was at a
really young age I knew something was
different Junior High locker room
situation that I was looking at the guys
and I was like I want to look like that
and then I was like no I think I just
want that I was really obsessed with
Jesse McCartney when I was 13 though and
I think that was a pretty clear hi I was
always told that I was gay so I fought
against it at 15 I had this felt like
are you gay and I was like no no no I
think I knew I was gay when I saw Danny
on the real world New Orleans oh yeah my
hometown in Iowa there were no gay
people around I was just like basically
asexual through high school it really
wasn't until I got to college when I was
actually around gay people college after
I got my braces off I just went that was
your awakening yeah her blossoming
moment is your teeth were good because I
was afraid to kiss people I was really
gone I was 12 when I came out I came out
at age like 15 it's a pretty young 16
when I came out I came out when I was 18
I came out to like friends I was 20 21
21 I came out at 22 and 25 now so I
haven't been out for very long at all
the whole note passing my mom found a
box of my notes from this guy I had a
crush on if you think why did why are
you writing to him I guess I was like oh
cause were practicing like as if I was
the girl oh she knew she knew she was
like okay mijo and I was like all right
they were like chatrooms
back in the day pretty sure I left one
of the windows I was chatting with the
guy on and my sister was using the
computer and I was like oh my god did
she click it of course she did my mom
discovered my internet search history I
rant
room I'm cried my dad found gay porn on
my computer I like almost threw up I
used to put old Abercrombie & Fitch
shopping bags with like the hot models
up in my closet in my room some sexy-ass
bags yeah pretty sure my mom saw it I
was outed on tumblr I had a good one
social media following the so did he and
it was opposed to anything he posted a
like explicit picture of his kissing I
didn't admit it to myself that I was gay
so I was like ooh
no and everyone started sharing it and
stuff Andy I mean me asking me questions
and I freaked out and I deleted my
tumblr also I had a cutout of a
shirtless Justin Timberlake under my
family bath towels my mom would change
the towel they were just gone one of the
days and I was like oh my god oh man so
much yeah there's a lot to be afraid of
when you're in the closet being judged
by society gay marriage wasn't okay I
had a lot of Christian friends I didn't
know how my church my community would
receive it I saw a lot of homophobia and
people around me I grew up in a town
that was really closed-minded there was
a lot of bullying going on I didn't
really know that many gay people growing
up there was no one I could even talk to
about it frayed of not loving myself if
I was gay getting kicked out by your
parents you know anyways not wanting to
be friends with you anymore your mind
goes to the worst-case scenario I came
out because I decided that I was tired
of being single and I didn't want to
date in secret I like wanted to share
that experience with my friends and the
people I was with I had been dating my
boyfriend for two years
my mom just kept asking me like when are
you getting a girlfriend I was so done
and over that question it was getting
like heated a little bit and I just told
her oh it was actually health related
stressing out about my sexuality and I
eventually broke out into shingles led
me down the path of coming to terms with
who I am I was going to like a really
accepting high school one friend in
particular who held my hand and took me
around the classroom and like helped me
come out to people so it was like really
hard it was easier to just like kind of
out deal with the consequences rather
than like keep it inside and have it
keep eating away at me tired of feeling
afraid to tell people wrote her a little
note mom I'm gay and then ran downstairs
and like gave it to her in the kitchen
then ran back upstairs before she could
read it oh that's a good way to come out
that's how I tell my mom everything I
need to tell her that's like I'm too
afraid think for me it was probably my
dad thought it was his fault but he like
didn't take me fishing enough I went
fishing all the time and I'm still gay
I love fishing I don't 102 my mom was
the hardest person to tell as a kid like
you're all their hopes and dreams she
took it really hard like to this day I'm
sure she still hopes that like I'd get
with a girl eventually or something I
had a lot of trouble in school with
police I took a very long time for me to
feel safe in my town in the school that
I was in in like everyone lied told all
my family all my friends just like one
friend from high school was like I don't
want to talk to you anymore
Wow the person I came out to last was my
mom you know I grew up really religious
we're still working on it now
she still believes that there's hope for
me to be with a woman when I came out to
her there were tears but ended in hug
a lot of my friends took it really well
a few months or years later a lot of
them came out to your so we like
unknowingly we're friends with other gay
people that we just weren't out to the
gay souls will always find each other my
mom was like why is he always around you
and like he's your boyfriend I just
stared at her and she's like AZ and I
was like yeah she cried but only because
I had told my friends and my sister and
brother before I told her and she was
sad that I couldn't trust her the first
is like a group of straight guy friends
they like Karl just be who you are we
love you just be yourself and that was
huge for me
definitely my mom's I had worked up so
much tension and so much anxiety over
telling her and then when I did she's
like I know I love you and I was like
that's it I was killing myself over this
for months
yeah you could came out earlier exactly
my little sister she actually pushed me
to start dating my first guy she was
like Carl we're gonna love you no matter
what you deserve to be happy
and I was like little sister come on
guys my church folk were actually very
accepting of me it wasn't like I love
you but I disagree it was just I love
you it was perfect I came out to my mom
I was 12 we were fighting about
something or other I was like mom I'm
gay and she was like honey I know like
I've known for a long time it was super
hard it feels bad man exhausting
changing the pronouns of people you're
hanging out with when they say what kind
you like I feel like they thank you
astonished by people who keep that up
for years and even decades grief I think
it's a weird mix of like anxiety and at
least for me like depression and
self-doubt when mixed all together just
kind of feels like but death constantly
that you're dealing with painful and
unhealthy and it really affects
everything you do you feel like you're
wearing a mask I think it can manifest
in physical ways it's just it's it's
really unhealthy to keep such a big part
of yourself such a secret it's hard for
people to get to know you because it's
such a huge part of who you are and you
never get to share that with other
people in your life I felt like I never
really connected with people on like a
deeper level I've built so many walls
that now at 27 years old I'm just
allowing myself to be free and be who I
want to be I realized that I had been
stifling so much my personality from
developing it's so hard to actually look
at some of the I am
like I'm gay back then I was very shy
very insecure now being unafraid to be
myself around people that I might feel
like my judgement has been really
empowering and freeing if you need to
tell someone something important write a
note and then run the [ __ ] away it works
every time cuz they can think about it
yeah
there's no like immediate yeah
[Music]